so what I want to do here is talk about
all-new all-different amazing spider-man
and the reason why is because this title
is a perfect example of how some things
in all-new all-different marvel aren't
really is all-new or is all different as
we thought they might be
so the amazing spider-man is not
actually a restart of Peter Parker's
history which is to say the story
doesn't simply start from square one
instead it essentially picks up with his
storyline prior to Secret Wars which is
both good and bad the good is that if
someone we're looking to get into
spider-man as part of all-new
all-different marvel they would only
have to read a handful of issues to
understand what's going on the bad news
is that because of the fact that amazing
spider-man is not a complete reboot the
first issue will leave a lot of fans
with a lot of questions about what's
going on and so what I want to do here
is solve this problem for you guys by
winding the clock back to the events
prior to Secret Wars and talk about
horizon labs superior spider-man and the
launch of Parker industries so horizon
labs was a group led by a man named Max
Modell who was Peter Parker's idol an
inspiration for getting involved in
science with horizon labs introduced an
amazing spider-man issue number 648 and
served to operate as a think tank of
seven lead scientists including Peter
Parker all of whom would use their
knowledge to continue the advancement of
science and technology and maintain
horizon labs position as the top
provider of the most advanced technology
in the Marvel Universe
now an amazing spider-man issues 698
through 700 and a story called dying
wish dr. octopus had been in prison and
the raft which was a prison for
super-powered people but was also dying
using a miniature robot that he had
created
he was successfully able to transfer
Peters mind to the robot and transfer
his own mind into Peter Parker which was
then used by Dan Slott to launch the
superior spider-man series with Doctor
Octopus in the body of Peter Parker
while superior spider-man would see
Doctor Octopus attending to make up for
his past misdeeds by acting as a better
version of spider-man during the events
of superior spider-man issue number 19
horizon labs was effectively destroyed
when the facility in superior spider-man
were yanked into the timeline due to a
failed experiment which again allowed
Dan Slott to begin the spider-verse
event which had taken place between
issues number 19 and number 20 however
as a result of horizon labs destruction
in issue number 22 superior spider-man
launched Parker Industries to pick up or
her
Labs left off however when Parker
Industries was launched the only person
to join over from horizon labs was a
Johnnie joffrey a woman who developed
reverb ium which amplify sound rather
than absorbing it like vibranium now for
much of the superior spider-man series
Parker Industries played a background
role in the same fashion as Iron Man and
Stark Industries what I mean is that
most of the stories centered on superior
spider-man himself and had little to do
with Parker industries which only popped
up in passing or if it's hacking Parker
Industries was part of a villains scheme
furthermore during his time as Peter
Parker and in addition to the
establishment of Parker Industries
Doctor Octopus introduced several
concepts that survived after the
conclusion of the superior spider-man
series and into all-new all-different
amazing spider-man post Secret Wars the
first of these was Anna Maria Marconi
originally a student at Empire State
University dr. octopus had actually
fallen in love with Anna Maria and
because she was unaware of the fact that
Doctor Octopus was in Peter Parker's
body to her eyes she had basically
fallen in love with the real Peter
Parker the second concept dr. octopus
had established was the reintroduction
of a robot by the name of the living
brain originally a character that had
appeared in the 1960s as part of the
original spider-man series under the
control of dr. octopus the living brain
was repurposed while it had only played
a background role I'd like you to keep
the living brain in the back of your
head because it will become an important
part of our discussion for all-new
all-different amazing spider-man having
said that in superior spider-man issue
number 30 the series effectively ended
when Peter Parker's mind resurfaces but
in truth this bit of writing was really
more on the order of Dan Slott having
written himself into a corner and kind
of forcing the reveal of Peter Parker's
consciousness existing in his body
alongside Doctor Octopus and so at the
end of the series Doctor Octopus
essentially gave Peter Parker his body
back and disappeared now following the
launch of Marvel now in 2012 and
Marvel's attempt to bring in new readers
and 2014 as one of the last publications
to be rebranded as a marvel now title
amazing spider-man picked up were
superior spider-man left off with Peter
Parker back in control of his own body
but also dealing with the realization
that he's now in
of Parker industries in the first
several issues model established that
annamaria had figured out Peter Parker
West spider-man as well as the fact that
the version of Peter she had fallen in
love with was actually Doctor Octopus in
addition to the fact that so Johnny
Joffrey was still part of Parker
industries working directly with Peter
himself and so what this does is allow
us to segue directly into all-new
all-different amazing spider-man which
picked up eight months after the end of
Secret Wars and the start of all-new
all-different marvel
I want you to get to you
so the colic initially picks up with an
advertisement from Peter Parker on
behalf of Parker industries with
something called web where as we're told
the wrist device provides unlimited
internet access data usage clear phone
reception and high-quality storage at an
affordable price all of which is
provided by Parker industries a global
company now this is one of the
unanswered questions from issue number
one and that we don't know what took
place to elevate Parker industries from
a successful startup company so one of
the largest technology companies on the
planet rivaling Stark Industries and
size however the advertisement is
revealed to be part of a marketing
campaign which is disrupted by a group
of thieves in Shanghai China what we're
told is that with Parker industries
operating on a global scale Peter Parker
himself works as spider-man on a global
scale as well furthermore operating
alongside Mockingbird we learn that
Parker Industries is now the main
supplier of weapons for shield now again
why it is that Stark Industries is not
supplying weapons to shield is not
explained in this comic but one
spider-man and Mockingbird catch up to
the criminals we learned that they're
working for an organization called the
zodiac what were also told is that the
zodiac were able to enter the Shanghai
branch of Parker industries with little
resistance indicating that someone on
the inside of Parker Industries is
working with the zodiac now
transitioning to San Francisco we learn
that in order for Peter Parker to
operate as a legitimate businessman but
ensure that criminals are dealt with
while he operates as spider-man where he
can he also brought in a hero by the
name of Hobie Brown to work as
spider-man all Peter isn't around now to
sidetrack for a second Hobie Brown was a
hero by the name of Prowler who for all
intents and purposes was basically a
poor man's Batman usually operating from
the shadows his biggest claim to fame
was during civil war when he was the
first hero arrested after the deadline
for registration had passed and so in
truth bringing him into the spider-man
group was an intelligent decision since
he was basically a character that Marvel
can never really do anything with now
while this scene only serves to set the
stage for how Peter Parker deals with
being a businessman and spider-man at
the same time the story transitions to
the wedding of max no Dell the former
CEO of the now-defunct horizon labs and
his partner Hector now the importance of
this
is that for Peter Max had been a huge
inspiration and his reason for getting
into science in addition to this horizon
labs had offered Peter the chance to
expand on his knowledge in ways that he
was unable to achieve before as a result
he took the step of appointing Max and
Hector to the heads of the West Coast
branch of the company furthermore in an
attempt to provide a haven for those
with an aptitude for science in the form
of the parker institute for technology
peter instead chose to rename it to
horizon industries as a tribute to max
and everything he had done for Peter
however in the midst of their wedding
reception the group is attacked by the
zodiac as they state Peter Parker's web
wear device allows for access to data
that would otherwise be restricted and
while he tries to figure a way out of
the situation without compromising the
security of his company or revealing his
identity as spider-man hubby Brown jumps
in wearing his spider-man costume but
because he does not possess a spider
sense and because his role as the
Prowler saw him working from the shadows
while he does his best against the
zodiac in the end he doesn't possess the
skills to overcome the group seeing the
death of hubby Brown as the only logical
conclusion to the fight Peter Parker
hands over his web wear device which
he's also encrypted and so with the
zodiac departing Peter turns his
attention to Sozzani revealing that he's
been reviewing security footage and come
to the conclusion that she was the
insider allowing the zodiac to access
Parker industries because the Johnny
wanted the company to function as a
conglomerate rather than a humanitarian
system her goal was to sabotage peter's
project in an effort to oust him as CEO
by their board of directors and replaced
him with herself however after being
confronted with this information so
Johnny agrees to step off and allow
Peter to pursue his vision for Parker
industries and so transitioning back to
London as a story comes to an end we
pick up with annamaria with susanti
returning and calling an emergency
meeting of the senior executives her
tone irritates annamaria who jokingly
instructs a living brain to execute her
while living brain states that his
programming doesn't allow it to kill
people and annamaria jokes about a
sarcasm upgrade the story ends with
reveal the Doctor Octopus had backed up
a copy of himself within the living
brains programming
with that being said we're going to
bring this video to an end and I hope it
made sense if it did let me know and I
will catch you guys later peace